[Music]
sir
this is the general
Ardmore
good to meet you colonel
for good things
But A lot's changed since your last tour
here walk with me
hi Mom
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
maybe I'm just losing it out here but
I'm seeing real evidence of a systemic
response on a global level I can't
I won't use the term intelligence it's
it's um maybe awareness is a better word
it's it's like the entire biosphere of
Pandora is wear and capable of this
cognitive response
I can't say that
tell him away from the kids
[Music]
he's targeting our family cannot ask
this the children everything they've
ever known the forest this is our home
children he had him under his knife
[Music]
my father gave me this bow as he Lay
Dying and he said protect the people
your thought of my dog
this will protect the people
has spider that kid knows everything you
know it's a whole operation
if the people Harbor US they will die
do you understand
look I got nothing
I got no plan
but I can protect this family that I can
do
[Music]
I know one thing
oh
wherever we go this family is our
Fortress
[Music]
laughs
you're so cool
[Music]
you saved my life
thank you
[Music]
buddy I have no idea what you just said
I heard you didn't they
[Music]
breathe in
and breathe out
imagine flickering a flame
you must slow down your heartbeat
breathing
breathe from down here
breathe out slowly
[Applause]
look your heart beat as fast sorry try
to focus okay are you there
and breathe out let your mind go clear
okay
so what is it
I feel her dad
I feel who
hey what
I hear her breathing
I hear her heartbeat
she's so close
she's just there
like a word about to be spoken
I know you think I'm crazy
[Music]
you're not crazy baby girl
so what does it was heartbeat sound like
[Music]
mighty
we had a costume designer Deborah Scott
Academy Award winner I'd worked with
since Titanic she had to kind of have a
foot in both worlds because she had to
design all the costumes for the RDA but
she also had to have the whole other
half of her brain to design all the
costumes and jewelry and hair designs
and hair decoration and everything for
the navi costume design is one of the
most important parts of expressing a
character how a person dresses what
their clothes signify in a clan people
who perform different functions the
leader the fisherman a child that all
these people have a different place in
the clan
researched indigenous people literally
worldwide the environment at which the
Clans live is extremely important to
what they wear
so the amount of kind are Forest people
they use things from the pandorian
forest the mankinda are much more
adapted to water you are not good divers
maybe good at swinging through trees but
one of the main reasons that we've made
the garments to completion is the motion
of the Garment
cannot be understood without having the
whole piece so if something's heavy or
feathery or light or stringy or fringy
the way these things move in air
standing in a breeze underwater for sure
which is a huge part of the movie you
really have to have the sample to see
what happens to it I honestly believe
that being able to create the garments
in their full Glory as opposed to just a
piece of 2D conceived artwork is
changing the way that digital films will
be made every Fabric and every woven
piece or every braid and feather they
all have their own life to them they all
move in their own way and that's not
something you can get from just looking
at a piece of artwork and translating
that to a screen we work with what a
digital on a constant basis even the
smallest thing like a necklace goes for
scanning where it can actually map it
they read the texture they read the
color and then they use all of that
information in a virtual world
the ability that reality that we're
managing to bring to the movie is a
hundred percent gonna make it just more
real for everyone
[Music]
there are different ways to make films
that have CG characters what we're
interested in with performance capture
is the totality of the Performance
Physical emotional facial the eyes
everything the actor creates the emotion
the actor creates the moment it's our
job to make sure that everything the
actor did is preserved in their CG
character you are very hard on them
I'm the father it's my job everything
that Jake Sully as a navi does Sam has
done
I thought we lost them
[Music]
you can capture the emotion you can
capture the subtleties the nuances of
the movements you can capture the eye
and capture the ticks everything capture
it all I'll be nice once
then I won't
the moment I saw her for the first time
I was just like you're just so beautiful
blue has never looked more beautiful
family
the amazing thing is that the technology
gives me that portal to bring my 14 year
old self to play this girl avatars only
go around
in making a movie set on Pandora
doesn't exist avatars don't exist at
nine foot tall we have actors working in
a volume with markers on their body
facial head rigs on their head and we
capture a hundred percent of their
performance in the digital world at the
beginning of the day the first thing we
do is get into the performance capture
suit and that is a skin tight two-piece
and it's totally filled with ping
pong-like pools around us so they can
then track my arm and then translate
that into the virtual world they have
all these little cameras that send these
little rays which give an image of you
moving around so every little movement
is your movement and then we put a rig
on and it's a helmet and it has a camera
that's right in front of your face one
of the big advances that we've made
technologically on the sequels is the
facial performance capture we're
capturing a much higher Fidelity of
performance I know one thing
[Music]
this family is our Fortress
I've done a lot of green screen I've
done a lot of blue screen but never
anything of course like this where there
really is no screen you're just acting
in a space no you must stand
I've always thought that being in the
volume is about playing and Imagination
and there is no kind of fear or no shame
you can do whatever you need to do to
get to that truth saving their lives
that's all that matters I have had to
work completely differently than I ever
have before and it's been an amazing
experience to go back in time
why am I different
[Music]
it is just remarkable to be able to see
the movements and the performance go
straight into the character and it's
like there's Kate and hey there's
Renault so that has been fascinating to
me what is this done away
what is this
I find as a director I'm much more
attuned to the actors because that's all
I have to worry about I'm not distracted
by the camera move or the extras in the
background I'm just there for them
that's all I care about that's all I'm
watching it's an amazing process it's
also the only way to do it it's the only
way to make this film
foreign
[Music]
she's so close
to be down like
mighty
wind cannot let you bring your War here
Outcast that's all they see
I see
this is our home
I need you
with me
and I need you to be strong
[Music]